ici embauché coiffeur depuis 40 ans et
même s'il est plutôt pour le prélèvement
à la source
il se pose encore beaucoup de questions
sur son application
la seule chose dont ils soient sûr c'est
que ça lui coûtera plus cher ça va nous
coûter pascal cabinet comptable va de
nouveau en profiter pour augmenter ses
honoraires ce qui régit qu'il va avoir
plus de travail donc ça va nous coûter
plus cher qu'il ya non seulement les
fiches de paie mais il ya des
déclarations qu'il va falloir faire vos
impôts le traitement de tout ça le
pourcentage qu'on va recevoir pas
recevoir le prélèvement qui sera fait ou
pas bref encore beaucoup de fluke pour
cet artisan mais ça devrait leur assurer
son expert comptable est prêt et il
craignait lui le report ou l'annulation
du prélèvement à la source de toute
façon c'est une réforme qui doit passer
un moment à l'autre du dessin pays des
seuls pays qui ne le fait pas oui
effectivement en envoyant que la
technique tout était prêt et qu'il ne
manquait plus que cette étape c'était un
petit collège et qu'un passé on arrêtait
forcément et pour cause directement
impliqués dans la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme comme toute la profession
ce cabinet d'expertise-comptable s'y
prépare depuis des mois voire plus si
hier soir il était dit on met de côté le
comme un investissement en tant qu' on
était un petit peu sortez pas de gâchis
plupart si on était du temps de perdu
pour nous les cabinets pour les ide en
logiciels pour toutes les entreprises
qui sont
lire les gens démissionnaire et puis
pour tout le monde puisque toute la
communication qui a été faite tout la
mise en place une mise en place en
janvier prochain comme prévu
de l'avis de buts est à la tête de
plusieurs sociétés d'événementiel et
nouveau patron des patrons de côte-d'or
lui prend acte
on n'a pas peur des boeufs en revanche
là où on a peur c'est plutôt sur la
façon dont les collaborateurs vont
prendre cet impôt à la source deux
collaborateurs qui ont le même métier vu
leur situation personnelle n'auront pas
le même montant en bas de la page
comment leur expliquer ça sinon en
rentrant dans leur condition personnelle
ce qui à la base n'est pas le rôle du
chef d'entreprise et on ne veut pas ça
aujourd'hui chef d'entreprise ou
salariés attendent tous la même chose la
fin janvier pour voir comment ce
changement va s'opérer concrètement